me
えっと私は今このように漫画を書いていて私は今この漫画を交えている時に一番大事に
しているのがいかにして人の心を動かすのかっていうことなんです
でその中で
その中でもっとも一番大事なのは
感動です
って私はこの感動ということにものすごいこだわりを持って生きてきました
実は中学校1年生の時に私あの漫画ではなくて演劇やってたんですよ
中学校の時毎年各クラス開講
演劇対決っていうのがあって
私は
初めてクラスの中で主役に抜擢されたんです
て周りを見てみたらなんと劇団
猛虎6ねやってますって子だったりあ系の事務所入ってますって子だったりが
めちゃくちゃいるんですよ
そんなまたで私あの発生レッシュのアイウエオで再できなかった自分が
志らくやったらどうなるでしょうか
チキンなんですよ毎日緊張してあっあそんなんですかーみたいな感じでやってたんです
けど
ただやっぱりマーヤ目立つというものが10回も20回も30回も繰り返されて
で
演技が上手い子からしてみれば私の演技ってなんで主役になったかわかんないんですよ
ね
当たり前かと思いますだからそういう子からちょっとした嫌がらせを受けて私は一時期
クラスの中で一人ぼっちになるってこともありました
でも私は決めていたんです
キャリアはないかもしれないでも一番伝わる演技をしようっ
それで私は本番の前トン超の後ろで
ガックガクする足を壊れて一歩前に出てセリフを発しました
よし20分間の間演じきって
最後のセリフを言いおいたとき
一瞬の沈黙が会場から流れたんです
そしてワット
関西が来たんですねそのエネルギーの波がこちら側に来て私はそのエネルギーの包まれ
ました
その時私の心の中からは
今までずっと感じてきた感情をすべてが爆発してきたんです
人生最高の感動的な瞬間でした
私はこれを
胸いっぱいの感動と名付けたんです
で中学校2年生の時に私学校転向したんです
ていろいろ
あの新しい出会いワクワクしていったんですけど赤石できるかもしれないと思って行っ
たんですけど
あの実はですね私教室のコミュニティに入っていけなくなってしまったんですね
いつも部外者のような扱いを受けて過ごしていました
学校が人生のすべてでした中学校学生だったんでね
ただ
なのでも終わった瞬間あの学校のクラスに入れなくなった瞬間天人生終わっちゃった
なって思ったんです
演劇部が唯一私の拠り所でした
しかし私は学校のその駒の先生からこう言われたんです
教室に来れない子はくれるわけないじゃんくり資格なんてないんだよって言われたん
です
その時
私は
本当に傷ついてしまいました
そこで私はもう学校にいけなくなってしまったんです
ずっとこのように家にこもっていました
心の中ではもう無気力だったんです何をやっても
チンに入らなくて仁川
どうしていいかわかんなかった
でもそんな時に
私は気づいたんですね
この無気力という状態っていうのは何か辛いこととかあと苦しいこと入れも増して人を
人としては生かしてくれないということです
ある日私はテレビをつけました
そこではあのフィギュアスケーター羽生結弦選手が表情軽やかに踊っているんです
でこんなに素敵なんだろう雲の家の存在だなって思ってたんです
しかし彼が
舞台を終えて
一瞬の注目が会場に流れました
そしてわーっとした感性がこっちに来たんです
この感覚に私は見覚えがありました
これは私があの中学校1年生の時に舞台に立っていた時に感じた胸いっぱいの感動だっ
たんです
そうだ
私はこの感動を知っている
本当はこんな無気力の状態から抜け出したいんだよ
もう1回目いっぱいの感動を得たいったから立ち上がろう
そう思ったんです
そして私はマンガン演劇の代わりに漫画をかけ始めました
3カ月かけて1本の作品を書き上げて出版社に投稿したんです
結果はダメダメでしたでも自分の心の中では
やり遂げることができたという達成感がありました
そして私は高校に進学しました
でまあいろいろやってきたんですけど
ふと考えた時に
あの漫画書いた時の感動って果たしてあのメニューがいっぱいになる感動だったのかな
って言われたら
実はそうじゃなかったんですね
あじゃやっぱり胸いっぱいの感動を得ようと思って
私は高校2年生の4月から6月の2カ月間
集中してもテスト捨てて書き上げたんです
なあそんなアジアの自分の年齢から転じておりました
あの順序17点ってことですねはーはっはっは
でも私にとって胸いっぱいの感動を得るってことの方が大事だったんですよ
最後の3日間寝ないで書き上げました
あの体すっごいつらかったです
でも
達成かもやっぱりあるけどあの胸いっぱいの感動ではないんですね
じゃあこれもっと上を目指す必要があるんじゃないかなって思って
あそうだ
失敗社に持ち込みしようと思ったんです
なので東京に行って傾向を持ってって
私は編集さんに結構見てもらいました
たくさんのアドバイスをもらって
私は札幌に帰ってきたんです
薬
2ヶ月後のことでした
一般の電話が私にかかってきたんです
それはあの出版社の編集さんからでした
君の作品ってすっごい熱意と情熱伝わってくるんだよねって言っ
だから僕これから担当になったから一緒に漫画作り上げていこうよ
この時
自分の思いが
伝わった瞬間だったんです
私は4年かけてこの腕いっぱいの感動を取り戻しました
でもこの胸いっぱいの感動っていうのを取り戻すためにすっごい苦労したんです
でもこれは
ものすごく人生を豊かにしてくれます
でも豊かにするだけではなくて強さにもなるんです
もし私が中学校1年生の時にあの女でいっぱいの感動を感じていなかったとしたら
私はまだあの無気力の状態のまま毎日を過ごしていました
でも私は今ここにいます
じゃあ
みなさんにもぜひこの胸いっぱいの感動を感じてほしいです
じゃっ通したらいいでしょうか
ポイント実は2つあります
一つ目はあなたがもし何かやりたいとかあるいは何かの役割を持っているとしましょう
それをできるかできないかは一切関係なくとにかく思いっきりやってみることです
それが一番です
そして思いっきりやったということのプラスアルファになることとして二つ目
相手に何ができますかということです
今やっていることが相手に対してどんなプレゼントになるんだろうということを考えて
みてください
なぜならこの胸いっぱいの感動っていうのは相手という存在が入って
ってで自分という存在がいて
で自分の思いが相手に伝わった瞬間初めて生まれるものだからです
そして胸いっぱいの感動を感じて
自分の人生を豊かにして相手の人生も豊かにしてそして幸せの輪を広げていたい欲しい
なと思います
もしかしたらそれをやっている時に本当に苦しくて
本当に自分なんてやだもうやだってぐらいの感情
回も感じることだってあるかもしれないんです
でも
皆さん忘れないでください
辛さというものは
a には続かないんです
あなたならやり遂げることができます私はそれを信じています
絶対にみんな幸せになることができます
だから皆さん立ち上がりましょう今がこの立ち上がる時なんです
なぜなら
あなたが今起こす行動は
世界中の誰かが必ず必要としているから
ありがとうございました
[拍手]